[Musique]
perdue aux confins de l'interminable
forêt landaise la plage de moliets
compte parmi les spots les plus
dangereux en matière de baignade et de
surf
[Musique]
des rouleaux impressionnant de puissants
courants de marée et une rivière qui se
jette dans la mer sont autant de facteur
de danger c'est ici à moliets petite
station balnéaire de la côte d'argent
que l'on trouve le plus gros poste de
sauvetage français
le temps d'un été une vingtaine de
jeunes sauveteurs va devoir faire ses
preuves
encadrés par une poignée de crs
en ce matin de juin on révise les grands
classiques du sauvetage en mer et du
secourisme victimes alors ya eu faut dix
ans des techniques
quand j'arrive sur une victime j'ai
jamais vu de techniques un côté dans les
paquets tu prends ton structure est
collé bien sûr dans le rôle des chefs un
costaud qui parle avec les mains
patrick salinas porte sur ses épaules
une lourde responsabilité il doit faire
en sorte qu'aucun accident majeur
n'arrive sur cette plage longue de 9 km
les sauveteurs originaires des quatre
coins de la france sont pour la plupart
étudiants futurs professeurs de sport
maître nageur ou sapeurs pompiers la
cohabitation avec les crs n'est pas joué
d'avancé
il faut dire que ce n'est pas rien ne
les réunit mais ici ils ont au moins
trouver un point commun l'océan et ses
dangers
monsieur homophobie
monsieur m'entendez
dès qu'on part en intervention les gens
au pire garde alors quand il ya deux
mille personnes 3000 qui vous regardent
le type que vous allez sortir ou la nana
elle a plutôt honte
le réflexe est plutôt de se cacher et
passait sous le sable pourrait à sa
serviette plutôt qu'à dira merci c'est
gentil merci
l'essentiel c'est que l'intervention
soit bien fait que vous soyez content
que nous sommes tous contents super ça
s'est bien passé
voilà le soir on boit
un jus d'orange et non pour une bière
alors bon une bière alors et voilà on
sera content après brest entre
dès le départ nos apprentis sauveteurs
sont donc prévenus ils ne sont pas ici
pour se faire engueuler certes mais
qu'ils ne s'attendent pas non plus à
connaître des heures de gloire
il
[Musique]
puis
lorsque les juilletistes débarque le
village de moliets connaît une influence
spectaculaire
en hiver on compte ici que 600 habitants
contre trente mille résidents l'été
oui
où
[Musique]
dans le rôle du jeune premier julien 24
ans et un diplôme de maître nageur en
poche des petits partis
il est 11 heures du matin comme tous les
jours c'est l'ouverture de la baignade
[Musique]
on va dire juste là ils sont arrivés
sont tous avérés ce week-end donc
forcément entre la semaine dernière et
là il ya énormément différents squares
et au moins le triple de la semaine
folle je sais par les buts à l'heure sur
la main courante
il y avait au moins 15000 personnes sur
l'album par facile
et dans l'eau j'ai lu 400 je crois
400-450 voilà donc
ça commence bien quoi pour l'instant on
n'a pas eu d'accident aujourd'hui
dubois
[Musique]
oh la belle série qui se prépare
voilà le beau char break de moliets sa
fatigue
voilà c'est les aléas
c'est les airs mais c'est pas grave ça
fait du bien
[Musique]
le char break autrement dit une
déferlante de bord
[Musique]
à moliets les vagues sont si puissantes
qu'une fois pris dedans on a l'étrange
impression d'être enfermé dans une
machine à laver
non
[Musique]
à
e
[Musique]
dans l'eau comme sur le rivage les
sauveteurs sont aux aguets il suffit
parfois de quelques secondes pour qu'un
incident survienne
quelqu'un qui a peur il est
automatiquement revenir sur le sable
donc il va il va nous faire face et va
essayer de rentrer et après on voit vite
les gens qui sont à l'aise dans l'eau et
les gens qui sont pas à l'aise on a des
gosses de 12 13 ans qui sont à l'aise
qu'ils vont passer sous les vagues cela
on n'ira pas aller chercher à côté de ça
on va voir des jeunes de 25 ans ça peut
arriver et qui n'ont pas l'habitude qui
sont pas à l'aise dans les vagues et on
aura en aura plus de probabilité d'aller
les chercher quoi
voilà bien qui va s'ouvrir ou tu va
rigoler ça va ya pas besoin d'aller
chercher le gars qui a les cheveux bien
grands écarquillés si la méfiance
conseillé à mon avis doit pas être très
bien en général on se rapproche on se
met devant mardon facile et si ça va pas
on va chercher
voilà
sur une plage aussi fréquenté il ya ceux
qui aiment se faire peur mais aussi des
inconscients tout genre
d'ailleurs les locaux de la gendarmerie
approche
il se pense quelque chose du côté du
poste de sauvetage
c'est pas dupes et ne s'est pas loupé
alors français
c'est le premier gros blessés de la
saison à venir
pour bien vous avez une bassine
j'ai perdu connaissance non se sentent
bien
10 et 15 centimes à tuffé voir il était
alors en train de surfer derrière la
tête il s'est pris une planche de surf
il est lui il a ressenti la même voulu
continuer à surfer quelqu'un lui a dit
et toi tu saignes alors il est venu vers
moi et on a couru directement ici ou
post de sauvetage c'est surtout ça le
problème avec les serveurs certains qui
débute pas
et avec le courant qui a ici pour en
latéral qui ici il se déporte dans la
baignade donc
une planche de surf dans la tête ça fait
ce qu'on a vu ce matin lanta ou alors le
mec
voilà
l'autre là ils vont encore atterrir dans
la zone ii bat encore à y rentrer berne
ammar justesse dérivés voilà et là il
est dans la zone de bain
et là on peut lui mettre un sac seau
jours
à cet homme est alors il va vous
expliquer quelque chose monsieur le surf
la jeunesse alors si vous savez que ça
fait là bas
eh bien vous débrouiller pourquoi sortir
dans l'habitacle
parce que moi aussi je fais confiance si
jamais son fidèle bras droit ou fait je
suis débutant comment on fait
certainement alors tu vois le joindre
mme ashton n'a pas de culture ni pour
vous ni pour eux si jamais je vous
revois sortir du court l'appliquent
arrêté municipal et ses 11 euros
je resterai en euros dans l'accord 1
voilà alors donnant donnant
c'est un moins 5 pour la bonne journée
ouais ça va aller on va aller à l'eau
ouais voilà les compacts et c'est
pourquoi ils sont comme ça aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils sont arrivés ils ont roulé
toute la journée connaissent pas
aux deux jours pour ce match up dans le
barbeau c'est super en forme ils sont
plus calmes jeudi à partir de jeudi
jeudi vendredi samedi et sont calmes et
nous en mettre au moins
[Musique]
pour les sauveteurs de moliets tous les
prétextes sont bons pour faire la fête
et décompresser comme ils disent
ce soir on célèbre un anniversaire les
20 ans de lysiane
[Musique]
mon pain seul dommage de sortir on est
sur la plage mais c'est quand même de la
tension c'est pas si facile que ce que
les gens croient de l'extérieur quoi et
donc le soir on n'a pas besoin aussi
d'être comme ça sur un bébé a fait ce
qu'on veut le soir si on veut faire la
population se couche à 6h du matin là
pas de problème on fait ce qu'on veut on
est grand principal c'est de l'or noir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est toujours comme ça la soirée
commence tranquillement au clair de lune
et au son de la flûte pour finir sous
les spots l'a été dans la fumée d'un bar
landete
[Musique]
je vais
à
le lendemain matin au camping landes
island de moliets c'est l'heure du show
préféré de christophe guillaume bonjour
à tous bienvenue allant du blanc je vous
remercie d'être là pour cette petite
information pour offert sur les sur la
baignade à moliets le matin à 19 heures
lorsque nous arrivons au poste la
première chose que nous faisons c'est
nous pas mis long la plage avec des
panneaux assez explicite avec des
baigneurs paraît et on en place toujours
devant l'abbaye
donc cet endroit là vraiment à éviter en
moins d'un quart d'heure les deux crs
font ce qu'ils peuvent pour rassurer les
vacanciers qui viennent tout juste
d'arriver
et on vient vous chercher avant que vous
arriviez dans les grosses dates où là la
fois c'est moins agréable
est passible de christophe là tu as deux
bodyboarder
enfin bodyboarder un baigneur qui sont
passés derrière et vient de piercings
n'ont pas l'air très bien tu vois j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont peur crois qu'il
faudra vous y alliez là et sonore à 150
et 200 mètres de la limite
[Musique]
m
pathé que je vais déclencher le niveau
là ok
il faut ensuite mon toit est forcément
le phénomène de buy in est sans doute le
danger le plus traître qui guette le
nageur
c'est un fort courant qui lors de la
marée montante descendante vos propulse
vers le large
je t'appelle parce qu'on va avoir besoin
de vous pour un treillage là on a deux
mecs qui sont passés derrière et on a
trois sauveteurs qui sont en train de
passer la barre mais ce matin c'est la
taille des vagues qui inquiète les
sauveteurs en mer aujourd'hui et se sont
un peu surestimé et ils ont passé là ils
sont laissés pendant un cours en ayant
passé avec une accalmie derrière la
barre en fait la première barre et la
baie ils appellent parce que ils ont la
trouille de revenir pour un si gros
c'est impressionnant ils se font un peu
ballotté
[Musique]
finalement il y aura plus de peur que de
mal surtout lorsqu'à la fin du sauvetage
on apprend que les deux nageurs à la
dérive était en fait de jeunes
sauveteurs désigné pour un exercice de
triage dans des conditions extrêmes
[Musique]
une fois la tempête passée les
sauveteurs reprennent une surveillance
étroite de la zone à
ah oui c'est là
la baignoire
allez
c'est vrai père
j'ai même une terre encore bien
devant leurs
un bon sauveteurs scrute ils observent
ils guettent mais sur la plage elle
n'est pas le seul à avoir ce regard
affûté
les sauces comme ici
ils ont obtenu spéciale où se trouve le
musée tour et voit il se remarque se
démarque
vous voyez les trucs alerte à malibu
voilà quoi c'est c'est le gars super
demain tu avec un malaise berdych au
cours sur la plage je plains se plaint
de grandes villes et s'il a sauvé les
filles du soir ah le fameux prestige de
l'uniforme
pendant ce temps la mer monte durant une
heure les sauveteurs s'activent pour
ramené sur le rivage les baigneurs
fatigué ce qui à bout de souffle
n'arrive pas à traverser le grand trou
d'eau qui se forme lorsque la benne se
remplit c'est à ce moment là que les
risques de noyades sont les plus grands
[Musique]
on a vraiment le sentiment qu'ils sont
très nombreux et très concentré sur
finalement une petite une petite portion
de l'océan ça m'étonne pas qu'il soit 25
parce que finalement quand on prend le
temps de regarder on a l'impression
d'avoir tout dans le mou sur la plage
sur l'echez eu la puissance vu le
dernier les dangers qui en était donnée
qui pas plus d'accidents que c'est en
fait donc ils doivent être vraiment très
présentes de longmont sont souvent
attention pour poser et pourtant
quelques minutes plus tard le poste de
sauvetage est assailli les jours de
grands blessés consultent pour une
simple piqûre la chaleur les pointes
noires
d'autres ont vraiment très mal et
nécessite le diagnostic d'un médecin
voire une éventuelle évacuation par
hélicoptère
un peu plus au nord sur la base aérienne
de mimizan
une fois de plus le médecin du samu et
le chef d'escadron dubuis n'auront
peut-être pas le temps de finir leur
repas et donc il se sent
[Musique]
après un départ dans l'urgence le pilote
du bus met le cap sur la plage de
moliets à 8 minutes de vol exactement de
la base de mimizan
c'est adopter la situation c'est la
croissance reste tram les gens ça
sans se presser dans les mentalités
le brillant qui veut les sortir de
situations difficiles
ravi d'avoir entendu le choc entre la
technique le mécanicien a lui aussi un
kern qui opprimait image un peu
difficile
la journée de travail a forcément des
missions dispose bien des missions
en bas sur la plage des sauveteurs font
le ménage des vertiges et que cela elle
parle équilibre que là on a préféré
poser un collier et on demande un
trimestre 500 sur place et des quatre
élèves
il s'agit encore d'un accident de surf
la demoiselle est tombé sur sa planche
et ne peut plus bouger elle est aussitôt
transporté à l'hôpital de dax avec des
cervicales sans doute très abîmé
[Musique]
le temps se gâte à moliets
on en bail rouge
ouais
[Musique]
ouais affirmatif chez bamboo de prendre
tous les vols dans le cloud
des éclairs sont en vue un peu plus loin
vers l'horizon
en quelques minutes la plage est évacué
[Musique]
la foudre à la très mauvaise habitude de
prendre pour cible le baigneur
courageux mais pas très téméraire
les sauveteurs et aussi se mettent à
l'abri
[Musique]
ils sont visés l'orage n'est pas ce que
redoutent le plus les sauveteurs ils ont
une hantise celle de devoir un jour
intervenir sur une noyade
un drame hier soir vers 19 heures sur
l'une des plages de la commune de
messanges dans les landes deux frères
originaires de pau sont morts noyés
alors été emportés dans un courant de
baïne âgé d'une quarantaine d'années les
deux hommes s'étaient aventurés en
dehors des zones de baignade surveillées
et sauveteurs lisant récupérer à 200
mètres au large mais n'ont pas réussi à
le réanimer
[Musique]
c'était sa joie à la fin du mois de juin
on était en étant transformé le poste 1
il était 18h à 18h45 et on a reçu un
coup de fil comme quoi y avait un
problème entre messanges et moliets et
les collègues de messages avait besoin
de renfort donc on a en a pris véhicule
on est parti et plus gros en arrivant
sur place
on a tout de suite compris ce qui se
passait quand l'hélico posé sur le sable
et les collègues est en train d'amasser
d'oxygéner de victimes ça marque c'est
des images qui restent pendant un jour
ou deux on voit plus l'océan de la même
façon pour ma part j'en parlais que les
collègues j'ai toujours je vois toujours
l'océan de manière ludique pour nous on
connaît bien donc ça m'a jamais paru
dangereux le soir de la noyade ces deux
noyades on voyait ça différemment quoi
je vais me disais ça en effet ça peut
être ça peut être ça peut tuer quoi donc
c'était assez impressionnant
après heureusement la saison était
beaucoup plus calme jeunes aux plus
anciens on est content que ça se termine
déjà les jours comme si c'est un peu en
c'est la fin d'un cycle que l'été se
termine
hop on rentre on rentre à la maison
voilà c'est plus la lassitude morale de
tous les matins et tous les jours faire
la même chose pour venir mettre les
baignades surveillées au bout de trois
mois et demi pour
on n'est pas mécontent pensée fini quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant que leurs chemins ne se séparent
c'est vrai ces jeunes sauveteurs s'offre
un dernier plaisir sur la houle de
l'atlantique
en se disant que finalement la
commutation n'était pas si terrible
[Musique]
je pense que tu en tireras way une
certaine satisfaction est assez fier de
toi
[Musique]
physiquement et mentalement on est super
fatigué c'est c'est indéniable en plus
t'as vu la plage et comment elle est
grande à chaque fois tu dois monter tu
dois des ceintures et on le fait au
moins quatre fois par jour
pour certains c'est là c'est aujourd'hui
le dernier jour ils sont bien contents
d'un physiquement mais bon au final la
plupart reviennent c'est que c'est pas
si mal que ça après trois mois de
vigilance extrême
après une centaine d'interventions de
sauvetage en tout genre la parenthèse
estivale se ferme enfin pour les maîtres
nageurs sauveteurs de moliets
[Musique]
dans quelques jours les arts
retrouveront leurs casernes les autres
les bancs de la fac
la plupart d'entre eux savent déjà
qu'ils reviendront bientôt sur la côte
d'argent
histoire de partager ensemble une autre
saison tout au bout du rouleau
[Musique]
non